[Applaudissements]
si vous avez grandi dans le même monde
que moi vous avez grandi dans un monde
en crise ce qui est totalement
suspicieux quand on y pense parce que le
principe de la crise c'est que c'est une
crête
c'est un moment on le passe et on fait
autre chose et pourtant notre époque a
inventé la crise permanente c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut désormais s'installer dans la
crise vous connaissez le principe de
wikipédia la liste des crises que je
vais vous donner maintenant sur les
crises que vous avez documenter la crise
moderniste c'est la crise de l'entrée de
l'église dans notre époque la modernité
la crise existentielle je pense que ça
veut dire que c'est dur de vivre la
crise d'angoissé que c'est tellement dur
de vivre qu'on a peur la crise
d'adolescence c'est dur d'être trop
jeune la crise de la quarantaine c'est
dur d'être trop vieux
la crise de panique c'est que c'est dur
d'être trop jeunes ou trop vieux du coup
on panique la crise de la masculinité
c'est vraiment dur d'être un homme
la crise politique c'est dur d'être un
homme avec du pouvoir la crise
économique c'est dur d'être un homme
avec du pouvoir et de l'argent
la crise du logement on sait pas où
vivre elle la crise alimentaire si on
savait où vivront serait pas quoi manger
la crise sanitaire quand bien même on
savait quoi manger peut-être qu'il
faudrait pas le manger
la crise de natalité pour faire plus
d'enfants la crise d'extinction pour
faire moins d'enfants
la crise de l'énergie on pourra
probablement pas les chauffer la crise
écologique ça va nous tomber dessus la
crise climatique ça va venir du dessous
et la crise systémique c'est la crise de
l'ensemble de toutes ces crises
connectées les unes aux autres
alors il ya une bonne nouvelle la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ces crises sont en
réalité le fait d'à peu près 120 ans le
travail collectif
ça veut dire que nous avons
collectivement travaillé très dur à nous
montrer que le monde dans lequel nous
vivons est en train de remuer et
pourquoi alors qu'on aurait pu se
déprendre de ces crises passées à autre
chose on continue à en produire bien
peut-être tout simplement parce que ces
crises vienne matérialiser le fait que
le monde dans lequel nous vivons est en
train de changer et c'est une nécessité
parce que de quoi témoignons nous
lorsque nous mettons à pied d'or de la
maison dévastation de la nature
destruction du paysage accroissement des
inégalités le monde dont nous avons
hérité contrevient à toutes les grandes
valeurs de l'humanité veut bien le beau
le vrai et pour autant c'est pas
exactement quoi mettre à la place du
coup on cherche et on essaye tous à tout
et n'importe quoi
et nous voilà projetés dans ce vertige
de progrès qui est notre époque ne sorte
que tout ce qui ressemble de près ou de
loin à un discours sur le futur exerce
sur nous une forme de magie alors pas
tous pas exactement tout si on fait
l'exercice
regardons comment les hommes des années
50 ans gérer le problème ce qui pour
nous nous semble inimaginable comme
révolution technologique aux hommes des
années 50 avait en réalité été
totalement imaginez on avait prévu le
téléphone portable
on avait prévu le télétravail on avait
prévu et les opérations chirurgicales à
distance par contre on n'avait pas prévu
les femmes dans les bureaux alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est si facile
d'imaginer que le monde qui nous entoure
le paysage technologique les outils à
ville va changer mais ces
transformations la culturelles sociales
qui sont de l'ordre de l'intimé l on
n'arrive pas à les voir venir bien
peut-être parce que ces transformations
l'a1
dans le futur que nous imaginons nous
aussi nous aurons changé que notre
énergie ne sera pas la même que notre
envie ne sera pas la même que nos
préoccupations ne seront pas les mêmes
ça ça s'appelle un biais de projections
toute sa vie un homme cherche la ville
de ses rêves le quand il la trouve il va
s'asseoir sur le banc avec les vieux
c'est confortable de parler du futur
quand on est dans le présent peut-être
parce que tout simplement c'est
difficile à vivre le présent et pour
cette raison le grand sacrifié les deux
siècles qui nous ont précédés c'est le
présent je vous donne un exemple la
crise de 2008 vient du fait qu une
petite partie des acteurs économiques
ont reporté une immense partie de la
population une perte
incroyable en imaginant que elle
pourrait être absorbé plus tard vous est
peut-être venu en voiture
les usines continue de tourner on a
toujours su que ça pollue et on résoudra
ce problème là plus tard le grand
sacrifié c'est le présent cependant si
vous prêtez attention à ce que vous dit
l'époque dans laquelle vous vivez vous
voyez revenir ceux présents de
différentes manières toutes ces
histoires de yoga les méditations la
pleine conscience être tout à ce que
l'on fait et puis par une conscience
écologique aussi qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une saison comment ça pousse à
légumes de toutes ces manières là le
présent revient et c'est pas forcément
une nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle parce que
là rien n'est plus fédérateur que ce kit
intemporel et ce qui est impersonnelle
le présent revient et là c'est une
occasion que nous nous donnons de penser
aux choses qui n'ont pas de date de
péremption à côté de toutes les choses
qui vont nous arriver
les grandes constantes des choses qui ne
changeront pas qu'ils sont là depuis une
longue nuit de siècle à nous accompagner
je vous donne un exemple la question du
voyage il ya une constance chez l'homme
de l'arrachement à son sol vouloir
partir s'est levé et rêve d'élévation la
conquête de l'air
le coût des voitures volantes aussi
toujours des voitures volantes un moment
donné dans le futur le voyage je peux
vous donner un deuxième exemple prenez
le comme une métaphore l'image du dragon
vous voyez cette créature jalouse qui se
mord la queue pour protéger en son sein
un trésor précieux à l'intérieur duquel
il faut aller métaphore politique par
exemple les capitalisme qu'il faut
dépasser métaphore économique métaphore
politique comme le totalitarisme les
totalitarismes qu'il faut vaincre mais
aussi une métaphore de vos vies
personnelles ce dragon c'est aussi
toutes les épreuves qui vous
accompagnent il faut parvenir à vaincre
et puis peut-être une dernière image la
plus importante de tout sans doute
l'image de la maison a grandi magin
permanente de la maison parler de la
maison à n'importe qui vous toucherez
tout le monde
la maison à l'intérieur de laquelle il
fait bon vivre quand la pluie vient
taper sur le carreau de la fenêtre la
maison allumés dans la nuit alors la
maison de briques bien sûr de notre
enfance avec ses greniers son sous sol
qui vient verticaliser les excursions de
la jeunesse et puis aussi l'autre maison
plus profonde encore la maison onirique
dans laquelle on va arriver
pensez à ça non non sont différents mais
nous rêvons tous tout le temps alors
chacun avec son style vous voyez selon
vos nuits mais nous rêvons tous tout le
temps à l'unisson
alors voilà on a besoin d'imaginer le
futur faire des excursions dans ce qui
nous arrivera parce que ça nous permet
de croire qu'on est spéciaux que quelque
chose de nouveau va enfin survenir dans
ce monde mais nous avons aussi plus
besoin aujourd'hui que jamais de penser
à ce qui ne changera pas dans le futur à
ces grandes images assez constante
anthropologique à chaque fois que
j'imagine quelque chose qui m'arrivera
dans le futur en réalité je ne sépare
les gens qui sont autour de moi tous les
malheurs du monde viennent de ces
occasions que nous nous donnons de
trouver quelque chose qui nous rendra
unique mais à chaque fois que je trouve
à l'intérieur de ma vie et dans le fond
c'est ce que nous faisons dans les
humanités quelque chose qui n'est pas à
moi un contenu un personnel et
intemporel je me donne l'occasion de
renouer avec la communauté de mes
semblables de ce qui vous arrivera dans
le futur
toute honnêteté personne ne peut rien
vous dire mais une chose est certaine
c'est que ces grands invariants qui sont
déjà à vous y attendre en paix merci
[Applaudissements]